we're being joined online by Governor
Mike Dunleavy he is governor of Alaska
previously served as state senator for
five years
governor Dunleavy thanks so much for
joining us show really appreciate it hey
Ben it's great to be here thanks for
having me so let's talk about what you
are doing in your state to reopen so
you've issued some some new orders that
allow people to reopen what exactly is
the status in your state so we're going
to what we Furr to as phase one we have
five phases laid out with phase one
basically let's uh folks get back to
getting into restaurants at 25 percent
capacity the restaurants will
reconfigure their indoor dining so that
families can come in get reservations
hairdressers nail salons spas etc a very
similar situation in that they do a
reservation there's a social distancing
to some extent in terms of the
configuration once again inside the the
establishments but again we're gonna
we're going to ease in we're gonna watch
our numbers and again we're gonna have
science drive this and data drive this
spend because our numbers are probably
the lowest in the nation and we've done
a pretty good job up here and so we have
to we have to also take into account the
economy that's the other part of the
pandemic that's the other disaster and
if we don't get it up running sooner
than later we're gonna have some serious
long-term issues so we're easing into it
we think we're gonna be fine we'll watch
the numbers will watch our ICU bed count
our are not numbers our infection rates
but I think we can do this so what does
it look like in terms of face mass
there's been a lot of talk about face
masks nationwide and locally is there an
order in place that folks are supposed
to our face masks publicly or is that
more up to public personal discretion
publicly it's personal discretion we
highly recommend it when you go into a
grocery store we have not mandated it we
hope that the the business owners are
going to implement some of their own
workplace rules and I think they will I
think they'll do it because they want
their businesses to be open they want
their businesses not to be known as a
place where you can get sick or get an
infection so I think what you're going
to see as a result of this is
individuals and businesses stand up more
than most people think I'm often asked
the question in interviews you know what
are you going to do to force this issue
or make this happen and as I've said to
people in our
conferences we don't force the people of
Alaska we don't force we don't force
entities we ask them to work with us and
when they work with us we get the
numbers that we've got and we expect the
businesses to do the same thing in other
words they're gonna want to have their
product or service move they're gonna
want to have customers so they're gonna
want to make sure that they do the best
they can to prevent a spread of the
virus within their establishment we're
Stephen without Governor Mike done lady
of Alaska so governor Dunleavy when it
comes to local control I know there's
some questions about some the orders in
Alaska as far as what localities are and
are not allowed to do is there sort of a
baseline level of opening that you
expect all localities to obey or do
local mayor's get to make the decisions
we work with our local mayor's it's a
big diverse state you know it's
interesting just like we're in a
federalist system in the United States
where you have states that we believe
governance closest to the people is the
best and so we work with our mirrors we
work with our local governing officials
and Alaska again is so diverse band that
you'll have a situation where you may
have one small town isolated hundreds of
miles from the nearest road no hospital
no healthcare and they may want to open
up slower because they want to be very
careful we'll work with them conversely
speaking you'll have other parts of the
state that maybe the infection rate is
very low or nonexistence they may want
to open up some things at a pace with
the state that'll work as well but we're
going to work with everybody individuals
as well as enemies municipalities
governors Dunlevy there's been a lot of
focus nationally on testing and the
ability to test what does the situation
look like as far as testing in Alaska
and what capacity for testings you think
is necessary in order for more and more
broad reopening to take place my
understanding is the testing was
basically to prevent overwhelming of the
health care system in case a hotspot
emerges but what is the status of
testing in Alaska so we're so we're
trying to test more people like everyone
else we actually produce many of our own
swabs here in Alaska the swabs have been
difficult to get nationwide
internationally because everybody wants
them at this time we're gonna start the
process of producing our own vessels
their own plastic vessels for the UH for
the tests and we're working on reagents
if we can get more reagents here in
Alaska we can test more we can help
track more where this virus is and I
think what we're gonna
I'm no doctor but I think what we're
gonna find been is that a lot of us have
already been infected a lot of us have
already had this virus but we just don't
manifest it in an illness and that's
gonna be that's gonna be important to
know again the testings gonna help but
we also have to keep in mind that we do
know that vulnerable individuals with
underlying health conditions and the
elderly are more susceptible to the
ravages of this virus and so if we can
work at helping them keep away from this
virus as much as possible test folks in
our senior centers test those workers
test our workers and our prisons which
we do we can keep our numbers low and
again what we're doing so far is working
we'll ramp up our testing we get more
reagents we'll test even more but we
keep an eye on if there's a cluster or
an outbreak in a locale we'll go in
there
well we'll assess what's going on we'll
see how we can make sure that that
doesn't happen again but in terms of
closing down the state the whole state
we don't see a reason to do that we'll
deal with each locale on an individual
basis and I think it's gonna work for
Alaska have you been able to ramp up
what they call contact tracing having
people who are able to run down then the
number of people who have been contacted
by somebody with Cova 19 after the tests
have actually ramped up that's been of
course one of the recommendations that
has been trotted out there is that
states should not only have testing
regimens capable of identifying the hot
spots but then enough people on payroll
who could actually contact race to make
sure that they don't spread beyond the
hot spot we've been we've been actually
doing the tracing and tracking early on
when we first got our case our first
case was a pilot for a cargo airline
because once again Alaska or
International Airport Anchorage we're on
the the the fly ways coming out of Asia
and Europe and so we were able to do
that and start tracking early and
because our numbers are low we haven't
had to put a lot of people on the
payroll for tracking but we're gonna
start ramping that up as well as you
know there's a complete I guess you
would say when I say tracking and this
is not a dystopian a nightmare where
we're we're gonna put people in a
database and then track them wait around
but for the purpose of this virus we're
gonna ramp up more individuals that are
going to be able to keep a database just
so we can find out what's happening and
dig down deeper but again we've been
doing this since the beginning we'll
just start wrapping it up
one more I'm suing governor Mike
Dunleavy of Alaska governor suddenly one
of the main centers of danger has been
nursing homes it's true across the
nation what sort of measures are you
taking in Alaska to protect vulnerable
populations because obviously not every
population is is of similar similar
vulnerability if they're young and
healthy there's a very very good shot
that you will be fine
even if you get cove in nineteen but if
you are elderly or if you're if you have
pre-existing conditions that's obviously
very different how is Alaska treating
differently situated groups so are the
folks in our institutions such as our
seniors in our senior care homes we lock
that down early because we knew that
this is going to be a population that
could be hit hard we watched what
happened in Seattle and so we locked it
down early we test our we test our folks
there we test folks that are going in
there to work we limiting very much so
the visitation into these institutions
including our prisons including our
hospitals a psychiatric hospital
including the senior centers and so we
really haven't had an outbreak in any of
those institutions and we want to keep
it that way the other thing we have been
which is very different than other
states is we have about 150 to 200
communities that are many many miles off
a road some of our communities are
hundreds of miles away from the road
some are even a thousand miles away from
a road and so they're isolated or small
they don't have great health care
facilities some have no doctors no
hospitals we want to make sure that the
virus doesn't get into those communities
and so we're very careful in terms of
travel not necessary travel going into
some of our communities to make sure
that doesn't happen and like I said so
far it appears to be working we're under
no illusion that we can stop the
infection we've always said we will get
more and more cases what we wanted to
prevent was this and this is important
not overwhelming our hospitals so since
we have not overwhelmed our hospitals
our ICU bed count capacity is about 45%
I should say right now we believe that
we have an opportunity here to revive
this economy before the economy gets it
gets it gets in more trouble one of the
things that's been fascinating watches
the media attack governor's who are
moving toward reopening have you gotten
a lot of flack from either local or
national media for reopening obviously
you've seen that sort of flack applied
Brian Kemp in Georgia haven't seen it
applied in nearly the same way see Jared
policy in Colorado perhaps that has to
do with political affiliation or perhaps
that has to do with the the crowding of
a state obviously Atlanta's a major is a
major population center have you gotten
any of the same sort of flack in Alaska
for it for your moves towards reopening
no we haven't we haven't yet because of
our numbers and the fact that we
actually file a science and dad and we
don't politicize it Alaska the other
thing with Alaska is we've had a history
of disasters in Alaska I mean we are
used to disasters in Alaska I hate to
say that earthquakes volcanic eruptions
floods fires it's a common occurrence up
here when this happens all Alaskans pull
together there's no you know there's no
discussion about right or left
Republican Democrat everyone works
together when we're in a disaster in
Alaska we work really well and so the
press has been focused on getting the
news out the people about our counts how
we're going to reopen the businesses etc
etc so no we've been spared that you
know with regard to governor's like
governor camp again I tell people
governor's know their state's better
than anyone else
I can't tell governor Kemp what to do or
what he should do he knows this better
than I do and vice versa
we know our state up here better than
most people again that's the whole
concept of states and federalism and
local control I think I think the
governors are doing the best job I can I
think the president's doing the best job
you can't nobody wrote the handbook on
this pandemic as we know Ben and so
we're going to get through this
it's just we're gonna learn a lot from
it go to mike dunleavy of alaska really
appreciate time sir and thanks for all
you're doing for your state and moving
in safe and responsible fashion toward
reopening thank so much for joining the
show thank you thank you very much
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content